from cnr.com Pro Biden Super PAC to
spend $1 million on Tik Tock influencers
the pack may have already violated some
of Tik tok's policies you know we got
enough problems as it is with Tik Tok
and their algorithm and all that and now
quote the effort is part of a larger
Democratic strategy to lure young voters
into Battleground States who uh in
Battleground States who polls show are
increasingly critical of Biden whether
over his age or issues like a stand
towards Israel Biden's re-election
campaign itself is amping up its work
with social media influences in 2024
though those Partnerships are currently
unpaid Daniel wessell a Biden campaign
spokesperson told Politico the White
House team separately is also flexing
its creator game throwing its first ever
influencer Christmas party last December
so there's this guy who made a video
where he was he his his uh Tik Tok he's
got 400,000 followers and he just yells
so he's always complaining about
something and he yells and he's
complaining about the economy he
recently made a video where he said he
was contacted by someone claiming to be
in the Democratic party who offered him
50,00 000 for a pro Biden post wow and
one post one post wow and he said as
somebody who sells shout outs and reads
like 50
$50,000 is a lot of money for a single
post
right
so the powers that be are ready to drop
I would assume more than $1 million on
uh getting people to claim Biden's the
right choice I remember back in 2016
there were a lot of high-profile uh
person personalities on YouTube that for
some reason we're just in favor of Joe
Biden and we like why but here's here
here we go I'm wondering what the
Republicans have to counter this I was
wondering that too that was my first
question is what is the RNC spending on
social media influencers and if you look
back at Biden's history in office and
his campaign he's been spending money on
influencers this whole time I remember
distinctly Jens saki had a whole Round
Table of influencers come into the White
House to tell tell them all to promote
the Ukraine war um you know I I forget
who there was reporting on that from The
Washington Post I think it was actually
Taylor lorens covered that we also had
remember the the the guy in the white
suit with no shirt yeah which I don't
understand a suit with no shirt like
that dry cleaning bill has got to really
be insane but um he was out there with
his fingernails and his cell phone you
know boosting the White House you've had
over remember that guy he was the worst
guy he was he was doing like a day in
the life
you know intern at the white awful and
then over the summer you had um was it
not this past summer but the previous
summer you had Biden brought in a whole
bunch of social media influencers to
tell them why it's important to have
child sex changes and all kinds of stuff
like that you had Dylan mulany in the
White House the dude was took his shirt
off and was like on the White House lawn
is that the one no that was that was
June Pride this year and it was and it
wasn't a dude no it was it was a dude Oh
I thought you were talking about there
was it was there was males and females
males and females the females had no
breasts and the men had large
on uh here's a question for you if a pro
Trump Super PAC came to us and said we
want to give you $100,000 to promote us
and do a read should we accept that I
don't think we should because number one
we're all actually different entities
and so it would be confusing to to see
our individuals opinions away from the
brand and they also think that
ultimately at least for me nothing to do
with like should the show except
sponsorship that's a political
sponsorship supporting a candidate if
they were to passay a lot of money
should I do like hey this episode's
brought to you by Trump is The best.com
credibility yeah I think it makes you
look biased that's what I'm saying like
I think even if there's full
disclosure I mean it's Tim show
ultimately so if that's what you wanted
to do that's fair but if we were
operating like the editorial board of a
newsroom then I wouldn't want to do it I
also don't like when editorial board new
I know that's what I'm saying I I also
don't like when editorial boards uh
endorse candidates I think that there is
a level of uh is scnr going to endorse
I don't know that's up to Chris candra
so I don't think post millennial is it's
up to Chris Cassandra I don't know why
we would it's up to Chris and Cassandra
because they're the editors it's weird
that news rooms endorse candidates I
don't I think it's super weird I don't
so my question then is for for you liby
yeah personally or organizationally
would you accept uh $50,000 to $100,000
in in support of from from a pack to
support a candidate to support a
candidate well like but I would accept
ad dollars we want a post that makes
insert candidate looks good
uh oh like sponsored content well
however however a pack would pay for an
influencer to promote like you make a
post saying hey this is me this person's
awes advertorial on the post-millennial
or human events or something I don't
think so I would take ad dollars if you
wanted to buy ads like for your
political campaign I would probably take
ad dollars for that I think that would
be fine I don't know that I would be in
favor of doing an
advertorial I I'm not I'm not crazy
about uh Shady post it's even more shady
when it's the like post it's it's triing
people look like it's organic and it's
not organic and they're paid I think
that's here's the bigger risk I'll tell
you the F the one reason why I would not
accept it because the rules around
political advertising are intense and
that's a nightmare to navigate well and
then you'd have to take anybody's
political advertising not necessarily
isn't that what the isn't that what the
TV stations had to do uh I I it depends
on the structure of how your ads are
done if you don't have the inventory you
can't sell the inventory we're so far
past TV if I own but single roll of
toilet paper and a Democrat wants to buy
it and a republican wants to buy it only
one of them is getting it but the bigger
issue is not if I had a single roll of
toilet paper I wouldn't sell it the
issue is not the the issue of is it
appropriate I think you end up running
into the problem of Democrats have no
issue whatsoever taking money from
powerful political organizations to make
fake content Y and then people on the
right are like well you know I think
that's wrong we shouldn't do it and so
I'm just
like yeah there's an issue of we have we
have we have limits on this show of what
we're willing to accept in terms of
sponsorship we've had people try to buy
their way onto the show we never allow
people to come on the show in exchange
for money that is not allowed and uh but
I recognize the challenge of so long as
people on the right who are opposing The
Establishment reject this standing on
their moral High Ground the Democrats
will keep having the advantage because
they have no Scruples it's one of the
things that actually works against us as
as conservatives is you know we we
wonder how do they always get these
people out in into the into these big
frenzy out into these Big Bobs or
whatever it's because Democrats are a
group mentality it's easier to her them
into one certain thing whereas
conservatives we're just like I just
want to be left alone just want to live
my life want to raise my family you know
start a business and in in this aspect
it's kind of used against us yeah I I
think that's similar I think the uh
acceptance for individual difference
it's much higher among conservative
communities than it is in on the left
which is sort of the inverse of what
they market right they say we're
tolerant we're accepting but we're
actually not uh we expect you to fall in
line and we expect you to be okay with
the things that we're okay with and I
think that's sort of the big lie that
they have sold a lot of generations and
a lot of really misguided people who
feel um anxiety within themselves they
don't feel comfortable with who they are
and so they think I'll just run to
whoever's accepting but I have to earn
that acceptance by complying completely
and totally with their worldview and
that's very different especially from
you know every every variation of a
conservative Community I've personally
experience that's interesting yeah it's
weird I mean I think it is the big uh
Democrats have and I don't want to see
Democrats left leaning causes whether
it's Democrat or just different
organizations have always done a really
good job of getting out ofe of messages
and spinning them and I think this is
something that Republicans struggle with
in this case like talking about
endorsement or whatever else like I
think ultimately I have to live with
myself and I would rather try to find
another way to tackle the advantage than
to just do what they're doing because I
again like I have to live with myself at
the end of the day well and back to your
point of the left like they they will
accept you until you step out of line
and it the perfect example of that is
the people were transitioning they sung
their praises and were like oh and then
when someone wanted to detransition
because they're like wait a second I
made a mistake they like the left
attacked these people and it's weird if
they were tolerant wouldn't they just be
like yeah everyone has a different
experience gender Journey or whatever
one of the most frustrating things for
me uh is daily wire uh posted a video on
X it's Ben Shapiro debating Destiny and
Ben defines woke and Ben is wrong in the
majority of his definition what did he
say he defines what
as this this idea ideology rooted in
post-modernism he gives a long
definition but he basically says it's
about power structures it's about you
know those who in power tend to be bad
and I'm paraphrasing rather poorly but
he basically gives this IDE ideological
woke is you know postmodernism with a
racial component and then gender
ideology it's totally wrong wokeness
means adherence to the social Orthodoxy
of dominant institutions that's it that
explains why so the issue is for someone
like Ben I can understand why he would
say it this way he's a Politico
political junkie so he's looking at all
the highest level things and wokeness is
identifiable in its root form the
average person who says woke does not
mean any of that because they don't
understand what that is and so they'll
refer to a woke person because they're
flying the Ukraine flag or something in
their profile picture why is it that
there's an overlap between those support
critical race theory gender ideology and
supporting war in Ukraine perhaps the
argument can be made that because Russia
is the power and Ukraine is weaker
therefore Russia is bad well that
doesn't really make sense because the US
is funding Ukraine to the tune of
hundreds of billions of dollars in fact
supporting Ukraine is supporting Western
imperialism and hegemony so why would
they support going to war against Russia
for Russia's border dispute we in the
west are the dominant power because all
that really matters is woke is a
reference to when someone adheres to the
social Orthodoxy of the dominant
institutions and it's a morphous
sometimes it's woke sometime like
sometimes it's see I woke in the
esoteric sense sometimes it's
postmodernist critical race theory
gender ideology sometimes it's
absolutely not and Everyone Falls in
line the the best way to understand this
is how the left uses a m and Bailey
tactic if the left was truly if woke
truly was postmodernism there would be
no mtin Bailey they'd quite literally
say here's our argument have a nice day
but they don't changed their argument to
a civil libertarian argument when
threatened showing there is no actual
ideology here it is simply just we are a
group that is in line with each other we
look for others who are wearing the same
color clothing and so long as we do that
and we are up to date on the on the
latest fashion we are aligned that's
what woke is I describe it as a a bunch
of birds flying in the sky flooding in a
random flooding flying in random
Directions They occupy a very specific
space you can see them oh they're over
the lake yes they have this weird
leftist postmodernist thing to them but
they're really flying around and they
can move at a moment's notice so I
tweeted a picture of something called an
ant Mill you guys ever heard of this no
no ants uh when they walk they leave
phone trails to signal to other ants
where they went what they're doing they
come back with food and they can follow
that line so you notice this in your
kitchen the line of ants an ant Mill is
when the ants get turned around and form
a circle yeah what happens is they
follow pheromones in a circle forever
until they run out of until they starve
to death what it's called a March of
death as well March of death a death
Circle in midle they'll just walk in a
circle until they wow because they can't
see the big picture yeah they're a tiny
ant and to them they're just following
the path and the path is one big circle
and they're all following each other and
more and more keep funneling in until
they eventually just starve to death or
dehydration and die that's wokeness you
join the circle they're all following
each other you say what is the ideology
they hold whatever the ideology of the
person in front of them holds it could
be anything well shifting sand that's
why wixon is offensive today but not
offensive tomorrow it's why women with a
Y is offensive today not tomorrow
because postmodernism is just a current
component of the cult ant Mill ideology
and it can become imperialist Western
hemony and a moment's notice yeah so one
day they're saying power structures are
bad the next day they're like we support
NATO expansionist on the Russian border
what thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net